hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the present age while he's talking
about this
very important process that he calls
leveling
in order to explain how it actually
functions he brings in another very
closely connected
idea and it really is an abstraction
what he calls the spirit of leveling or
the public he says for leveling
really to take place a phantom must
first be raised
a monstrous abstraction and all
encompassing
something that is nothing a mirage
and this phantom is the public
so it's something that you know to use a
famous phrase
is everywhere and nowhere it has its own
peculiar
sort of we might call it parasitical
being and yet
it's nothing and so
you know this sounds rather strange and
paradoxical
how can something that isn't anything
encompass everything at least within the
social world
and drive this this process that
kierkegaard thinks is so absolutely
essential and so dangerous
well there is this this abstraction
and it tells us that only in a
passionless but reflective age
can this phantom develop and he says
with the aid of the press
when the press itself becomes a phantom
now
it's very important to take into account
what he says next
in part because it would be very easy to
say oh a kierkegaard
you're disregarding how important the
public has been
in the development of the public sphere
and publicity and public opinion
and all these things that have driven
progress or at least you know
you can you can say well it's associated
with this institution or these people
he tells us okay sure
there is no such thing as a public as
he's calling it
in spirited passionate tumultuous times
even when a people wants to actualize
the idea of the barren desert
destroying and demoralizing everything
why because there are parties
and there is concretion and he says in
such times the press
will take on the character of concretion
in relation to the division
so you know if we think about our own
times
where you know the press is is divided
among all these different
sort of orientations and factions
you could say that fox news is not
actually
the public in the sense that kierkegaard
is talking about
nor would be msnbc
or you know a sort of left-wing
publication like jacobin none of these
would actually
be the public or the press as
such as kierkegaard is describing it
instead of something
that is in some respect more amorphous
more widespread you could ask well what
do all these actually
share in common with each other in terms
of assumptions they may disagree
about certain things but perhaps there's
some bedrock that they're all
established upon and he tells us that
just as sedentary professionals are
prone to fabricating fantastic illusions
so a sedentary reflective age devoid of
passion
will produce this phantom if the press
is supposed to be the only thing which
the weak itself maintains a kind of life
in this somnalescence the public
is the actual master of leveling for
where there is approximate leveling
something is doing the leveling
that is when you know something is a
concretion
he's talking about something an
institution an organization
a class that's doing the leveling it's
not yet the public he says the public
is a monstrous non-entity
so it develops with the aid of the press
the press can be
a phantom like it and he tells us that
you really can only have the public in
modern times and in some respect you
know we think about
the development of the public sphere as
one of the key ideas of
not key ideas one of the key features
of modernity right and so
why couldn't the public develop in
other times well he tells us about
antiquity says
when the people were obliged to come
forward in the situation of the action
they had to come
forward as a whole they were obliged to
bear the responsibility for what was
done
by individuals in their midst while in
turn the individual was obliged to be
present in person
as the one specifically involved only
when there's no
there's one feature of only when there's
no strong communal life to give
substance to the concretion
will the press create this abstraction
the public
he says made up of unsubstantial
individuals
who are never united or never can be
united in the simultaneity of any
situation or organization
and yet are claimed to be a whole now
think about all the times in which
you've seen people within the press in
newspapers
in you know cable television in opinion
pieces
claim to speak on behalf of
the people the public you know what
everybody
knows and they'll have like a few people
that they've interviewed
i can tell you having been interviewed
many times that quite often reporters
will use just a snippet of what you say
and often take it out of context
to make it fit what they want to say
it's a
disconcerting thing to happen to you the
first couple times
after a while you kind of get used to it
so you might want to
just a side note if you're getting
interviewed say
you can't use me unless i get approval
of what you're going to write
or unless you're going to quote me in
full you get you don't get to quote me
at all
right those are ways to try to try to
counteract this
now that's something that becomes
possible in modern late modern
post-modern whatever we want to call
our times and even more so because
of uh you know the prevalence of what we
call
social media and the electronic network
that we all live within
now or set of networks but it was also
going on in kierkegaard's time as well
so he goes on and he tells us that
the public is a core that is
a group of of people ostensibly
uh outnumbering all the people together
but this core can never be called up for
inspection indeed it cannot even have so
much as a single representative why
because it's an abstraction at the same
time anybody can
claim to speak for the public or put on
a show for the public he
he goes on a little bit later and says
that a sailor
demonstrating a peep show can can claim
a
public right now of course the public
can turn against them
as well so that's that's one very
important aspect
another really key aspect of this is he
says
it includes everything or at least it
purports
to do so right and he says that
if the age is reflective devoid of
passion obliterating everything that's
concrete
the public becomes the entity that is
supposed
to include everything and he goes on a
little bit later
and talks about how you know when we
have
actual persons and when we have
majorities and minorities that are
arguing with each other right the person
who's with actual persons
in the contemporary of the actual moment
and the actual situation
but has no opinion himself adopts the
same opinion as the majority or if he's
more argumentative as the
minority says both the majority and the
minority
are actual human beings and so you can
have solidarity with them
but the public is an abstraction he says
in adopting the same opinion as these
are those particular persons
you're taking on a kind of risk if they
are wrong you're wrong right
but the public is never wrong he says
here we go the public is a phantom that
does not allow any personal approach if
someone adopts the opinion of the public
today
and tomorrow is histon booed for taking
on that opinion of the public
he is historied by the public
a generation a nation a general assembly
a community a man can have a
responsibility to be something
can know shame but a public remains the
public
he says the public can become the very
opposite
and is still the same so
the public in a certain way is is
amorphous
abstraction ambiguous abstraction
it can become whatever it it wants to be
right it can it can change into its
opposite and yet remain
the same there's a again a
paradoxicality to that
he also talks about another really
important feature
it's it's an abstraction that as he says
alienates individuals instead
of helping them and
you know that that's a strange thing to
say isn't it
he also talks about it as in a certain
respect
educating them as
telling them what they ought to think
how they ought to be
an education here should be understood
not just in the sense of imparting
information
but in terms of shaping
in terms of building
in terms of orienting people
to to be a certain way including to
value what it is that the public has to
say
another key aspect of this he talks
about well how do individuals
actually get into this and he talks
about
nobodies so he says that
um the public is not a people not a
not a generation not one's age not a
congregation
not some particular persons these are
concretions and then he says yet
yes not a single one of these who belong
to a public is essentially engaged in
any
way for a few hours of the day he is
perhaps
part of the public that is during the
hours
when he is a nobody because during the
hours in which he is the specific
person he is the center of agency
responsibility
accountability right he doesn't belong
to the public
composed of some ones such as these of
individuals in the moments
when they are nobodies the public is a
kind of colossal something an abstract
void and vacuum that is
all and nothing so
it is in a certain sense parasitic you
can't have a public
without having people and having
individuals but those individuals can
each of them
not necessarily totally give up and put
aside their individuality but
operate within the mode of being nobody
being just part of the public at least
some of the time and you know
kierkegaard
is not saying that this is uh avoidable
for
for any of us all together maybe there's
some points in time where we all in late
modernity will be part of this
vast network that is the public
but he is saying it doesn't have to be
like that all the time
and so you know he goes on and he tells
us
that
in our time in this state of indolent
laxity
more and more individuals will aspire to
be nobodies
in order to become the public
the sluggish crowd which understands
nothing itself and is unwilling to do
anything that gallery public now seems
seeks to be entertained and indulges in
the notion that
everything anyone does is done so that
it may have something to gossip about
there is a defamation of the mind that
is brought about by
valuing the public and wanting to
be connected with it to be associated
with it even those who would
claim to rule the public to be the taste
makers
the opinion formers or whatever we want
to call them thought leaders are a great
example
really are a danger for just getting
sucked into
this public and essentially functioning
as nobodies even when they claim to
represent it
so this is this is another key aspect of
it we can desire to become
nobodies so as to fit ourselves into the
public
he finishes with his discussion of the
public by saying we could imagine it to
be sort of like those
old roman emperors who you know they got
to figure out what to do with the day
we're not talking about dynamic roman
emperors who are defending the borders
from
um you know barbarian hordes or whatever
you know
any of that sort of stuff he's saying
about the the fat old guy
sitting around having grapes put into
his mouth and
wondering what to do now with his time
and he talks about this kind of
person and the public is like this is
being more sluggish than
evil being more indolent and also
craving entertainment
craving something new it's driven
by a curiosity by variety
a need to see something happen and
perhaps also
by a sort of cruelty and here's where he
brings himself into the story a little
bit
if you don't know cern kierkegaard got
made fun of
uh quite a bit by the press in his own
time
and he's got this discussion about the
dog as being
sort of well he calls it the
contemptible part of the literary world
and then he says
if a superior person shows up perhaps
even a man of distinction
the dog is goated to attack him the dog
goes after him and then the
until the public gets tired of it and
says that's enough now so the public
does its
leveling the superior one has been
mistreated and the dog
remains a dog that even the public holds
in contempt in this
way the leveling has been done by a
third party
the public of nothingness has leveled
through a third party that in and
through its contemptibleness
was already more than leveled and less
than nothing
and he says the public is unrepentant
because the public didn't do it the dog
did it right
just as he says in in households
somebody knocks over something oh the
cat did it right
poor cats get blamed for all these sorts
of things
and so this is another place where if we
if we get away from kierkegaard himself
and we think about what he's talking
about here
the things that are concretions that are
still driven by
associations of individuals can become
part of this
process of leveling in what they're
doing for the public you know when
somebody is
essentially torn down within today's
media although of course today's media
is quite polarized
this process of leveling
is is taking place in the way that
kierkegaard is describing it so
the process of leveling in the present
age
is is in in fact being driven
by and taking place through the medium
of this
abstraction which is you know you might
say living rent free in all of our heads
and hearts if we allow it to
the public and it's closely associated
phantom of
the press
you